november passiert habe ich gut
position als skandal und innsbrucker
bischof von rom und papst oberhaupt der
römisch-katholischen kirche ist eine
weltbekannte figur
es gibt tausende stunden mit
filmmaterial über ihn
und doch gibt es jetzt noch einen
eigenen dokumentarfilm ein filmporträt
und wer wurde damit beauftragt dabei die
regie zu führen
niemand anderer als der deutsche
regisseur wim wenders die aussaat liebt
und sie uns alle in vancouver hat tornos
zentraler strang des films sind
interview passagen in denen franziskus
in seiner muttersprache spanisch zu
themen auskunft gibt oder sich äußert er
spricht sehr offen in erster linie über
dinge die die moderne welt betreffen das
ist gewissermaßen das gemeinsame
interesse von wim wenders und papst
franziskus homosexualität der
missbrauchsfälle in der katholischen
kirche die pädophile hin gilt null
toleranz
ein weiterer aspekt des films ist das
wie wenn das als kommentator oder dass
wir wenn das sich selber als erzähler
einbringt er lässt uns daran teilhaben
was seine beziehung zu diesem papst ist
als ein mann der persönlich nicht
anhänger des römisch geprüft haben ja
hier stehen wir alle miteinander mit
großen erwartungen
habe es vom amerikanischen kontinent es
zweifellos interessant schon aufgrund
des materials das so zu sehen bekommt
und auch aufgrund dessen dass man eben
dann doch einen sehr um gefahren zugang
zur franziskus als mensch als person und
vielleicht auch als papst es ist eben
nicht so leicht zu trennen bekommt man
hätte sich den film vielleicht ein
bisschen dokumentarischer vorstellen
können also in sofia an als wenn das
vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen
stärker nicht so sehr den blick dass
besorgten zeitgenossen auf francisco
seite richten können sondern auch den
blick auf einen mann der jahn und doch
so etwas wie ein weltstar ist und von
dingen umgeben ist die auch von
interesse sind so es ist eher ein film
geworden der wohl die botschaft oder das
interesse des vatikans sehr gut vertritt
nämlich den heiligen vater als eine
zutiefst menschliche figur zu zeigen als
eine figur die auf die sorgen und auf
die anliegen der menschen eingeht und
will wenn das der offensichtlich ein
bisschen damit hart wie die dinge auf
diesem planeten laufen sieht in
franziskus nun eine identifikationsfigur
über den engeren kreis der gläubigen
hinaus dafür dass vielleicht die dinge
dieser welt sich wieder in die richtige
richtung wenden wenn wir nur alle auf
dem papst mehr hören würden und der film
gibt uns dazu gelegenheit und das ist
wohl auch die zentrale
existenzberechtigung von franziskus ein
mann seines wortes
einfach besser
papa ist da composites
der mutter oder vater wir haben uns hier
[Musik]